[موسيقى]
كيف كيف
انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ولكن مع الاسف ان ابواب الجامعات والمدارس
مغلقه امام الفتيات الافغانيات لا لجامعه
طالبان
هذه المقاطع تزامنت مع اليوم العالمي
للتعليم الذي خصصته اليونسكو هذا العام
لدعم الافغانيات في حقهن بالتعليم حيث طلب
الامين العام للامم المتحده الحركه
بالعدول عن قراراتها التي منعت اكثر من
مليون فتاه من الالتحاق بالمدارس واكثر من
مئه الف طالبه من ارتياد الجامعات ومنع
مئات الالاف منهن من العمل
[موسيقى]
ضاعفت الامم المتحده جهودها لاقناع الحركه
بالتراجع عن قراراتها عبر وفود الامميه
وانسانيه حيث جمدت العديد من المنظمات
الاغاثيه نشاطها في افغانستان بعد قرار
الحركه منع الافغانيه من العمل في هذه
المنظمات
الامر الذي يعرض الملايين من الافغاني
لخطر المجاعه
انا سنماسي العربيه